The Unusual Origin of
Scrabble
There aren’t a great number of positive
things that can be attributed to the Great
Depression.
However, Scrabble is a game that probably
wouldn’t have existed without it.
It all began with an unemployed architect
by the name of Alfred Mosher Butts of Poughkeepsie,
New York.
Thanks to his excessive free time while unemployed,
he decided to invent a word game that was
inspired by anagrams and crossword puzzles.
Butts’ decision to go with a word game was
partially from previous study he’d done
into popular games.
In his 1931 paper, aptly titled “Study of
Games,” he noted that nearly all popular
games of the day were either strategy “move-based”
games, number games, or letter games, with
the former two being most popular.
He felt that the third category had quite
a bit of untapped potential.
A few years later, he put the finishing touches
on the prototype of his own letter-based game.
Butts originally called his game ‘LEXICO’
and it didn’t require a board to play, simply
comprising of small cardboard squares with
letters on them; otherwise the game was very
similar to the modern version.
The letters even had their signature point
values.
He determined these values by performing a
frequency analysis on the alphabet from sources
such as the New York Times.
In order to combat the lazy use of plurals,
he only included four ‘S’ tiles.
By 1938, Butts changed the name of his game
to Criss-Crosswords and had added a 15×15
board.
Although he personally developed multiple
sets in attempt to sell them to large game
manufacturers, he was unsuccessful in this
venture.
An entire decade passed before Butt’s game
began getting any kind of recognition.
Things changed when a Connecticut man by the
name of James Brunot happened to have a copy
of Criss-Crosswords and believed that it could
be commercially successful.
He subsequently bought the manufacturing rights
from Butts, on the condition that the latter
would get royalties on every copy sold.
Once he owned the rights, Brunot decided to
tweak things somewhat, such as shifting the
starting point to the middle, instead of the
top left corner, and renaming the game Scrabble,
which means “an act of scratching or scrambling
for something” (from the Dutch “schrabbelan”).
He also re-designed the board slightly, including
coming up with the now familiar colour scheme.
After perfecting the game, Brunot and his
wife setup shop in an abandoned schoolhouse
in Dodgingtown, Connecticut.
Despite Brunot’s enthusiasm, only a couple
of thousand units were sold during Scrabble’s
first year of production.
After expenses, this actually resulted in
a net loss of $450 that year (about $4,200
today).
Business remained slow until a couple years
later when Macy’s president, Jack Strauss,
played the game while on vacation in 1952.
Upon his return, he was shocked that his store
didn’t sell the game and proceeded to place
a large order.
Apparently his hunch about the game was correct,
because within twelve months it was the ‘must
have’ game for most American households.
Thanks to the huge surge in orders, Brunot
could no longer keep up with the demand, so
licensed the rights to game maker Selchow
and Righter.
Two years later, sales of the game had risen
to over four million sets sold.
Not bad for a game that Selchow and Righter
had previously rejected back when Butts was
the owner, as did Milton Bradley and Parker
Brothers.
While you’ll often read that Butts ultimately
did not receive anything for the game he invented,
this isn’t true at all.
By the time Brunot sold the trademark rights
to Selchow and Righter (rather than just licensing
the game to them) in 1971, Butts’ had received
about $265,000 in royalties (approximately
$2 million today).
Brunot fared better walking away from the
whole thing with about $1.5 million (about
$11.5 million today).
The game was still going strong thirty years
after its big boom when Selchow and Righter
was sold to Coleco.
Unfortunately, the latter company went bankrupt
shortly afterwards, but Scrabble was quickly
snatched up by Hasbro and later the international
rights were acquired by Mattel for $90 million.
Today, Scrabble seems to be as popular as
ever.
Besides its online and otherwise digital popularity,
it is estimated that roughly one third of
US households contain a physical copy of the
game, as well as a little over half of all
households in Great Britain.
To date, over a hundred and fifty million
sets have been sold worldwide, making it one
of the most popular board games of all time.
Bonus Facts
• Leo Fender of Fender guitar fame was also
out of work thanks to the Great Depression
when he decided to start his own company,
Fender Radio and Record Shop.
He was previously an accountant.
Despite going on to be famous for his guitars,
Fender never learned to play the guitar, hiring
musicians to test out his designs instead.
• Alfred Butts invented another game in
1985 which was rather aptly titled Alfred’s
Other Game.
It still included words and points, but had
more of a solitaire type gameplay to it.
• Besides inventing Scrabble and his other
game, Butts was also an amateur artist.
The Metropolitan Museum of Art is in possession
of six of Butts’ drawings.
• There was a Scrabble game show that ran
from 1984 – 1990.
It contained a ‘crossword’ round and a
‘Scrabble sprint’ round to determine the
winner of that weeks show.
The very existence of such a show may seem
strange, but there also used to be a Cluedo
game show in Australia and the UK during the
nineties.
It was amazing.